hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on phone again we have
some interesting news to talk about
today we have a new road map for the
month of July and this will also show us
the reveal stream for the new character
in season 11 this is only going to be
the reveal stream this won't actually
tell us that the road map didn't
actually tell us what day he's actually
going to launch just the stream that
we're gonna know all the juicy details
about so as always like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe for new a cover the
informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the petrous and leaks if you
want to be kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on nothing definitely
stay subscribe to the channel and that
let's get started real quick I just want
to make a quick note if it sounds like
I'm super dead at when I'm talking do
not worry I'm not dying or anything like
that I'm completely fine I'm just
running off of 0 hours of sleep I
haven't slept in 28 hours the only
reason I stayed up is because a stranger
things season 3 had released today and I
stayed up and I watched the entire
season so great season totally worth it
I'm super [ __ ] tired and but
regardless we have a new roadmap to talk
about and it's gonna be about the new
season and that's going to be revealed
to us on July 25th and that will show us
the season 11 hero and we get to hear
about the whole newest addition to
foreigner what he's gonna come with he
character she character stuff like that
and I'm assuming of trends you know make
sense and if we go and you know some
type of order for this year we most
likely will be getting some type of
trailer for this character come the week
before that reveal stream so that's
gonna be super exciting we're gonna be
figuring out the main gender of the
character whether it can be it's you
obviously it's going to be female and
male but a lot of people like to
associate hito carries a female I'm
totally cool with that I'd love to know
the characters actual name and a bunch
of other stuff that's gonna be coming
with that character so definitely be
gonna be I'm gonna be covering that as
soon as that goes live on the 25th so do
not worry about that other notable
things is that we're gonna be knowing
the faction or more results on the 13th
so if we look out for that because I'll
be showing off the winning faction which
is going to be the Vikings and what
they're going to be receiving as well as
what the samurai will beginning with the
Knights will beginning as well other
than that dance of death is going to be
live on July 11th and there's going to
be an event order going along with dance
of death which is where the winning
faction gets steel and crates for the
most wins in the dance of death game
mode there also will be content
and there's going to be content the day
of that other stream on the 25th so that
we look out for that I'll cover the
content in a little bit and that the
last interesting no on the roadmap is
that the double xp is going to be on
July 19th for anyone that wants to grind
a little bit
judging from it it says July 19th to the
22nd so I'm assuming it's going to be a
weekend so definitely try to set that
aside if you're trying to grind some
characters as for the for honor II mode
contest which we've talked about
multiple times in my past videos the
winners will be picked and decided by
the end of this season so hopefully we
will know the full winners which may end
up being the content of the week during
that reveal stream so that's going to be
super exciting I cannot wait to see what
we're gonna be getting what these new
emotes are what the community has come
up for us because hopefully they're good
on top of that there's going to be a
discount on a huge champion mythic set
which is the set with fireworks and the
new content of the week is going to be
elite outfits so I'll show those
on-screen if you guys want to grab those
and yeah guys that was really about it I
just wanted to make a quick note like I
said if you do want to if you didn't
want me to talk a little bit more about
the picture it does look like there's
going to be lots of waves it just looks
like from the photos lots of waves
rushing and some rocks on the shore I
really have no clue what this means I'm
assuming one of you will probably figure
this out I have no clue this means at
all I'm just picturing that this is some
type of this person is born or this
person is no stationed you're some type
of Shore area Harbor dock type stuff
kind of like the harbor map that we have
but more of a Viking style that's just
my interpretation I don't know what this
is maybe just really cool fancy art I
don't know if foreigner likes to do that
sometimes but either way on the 25th
they will be showing off all this stuff
and I'll be covering everything they
show in that stream so do not worry if
you can't make it all someone is off
before you guys no problem
yeah like the view if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I cover the
informational side of foreign that being
the balance changes the hero updates the
patch with some leaks if you want to be
kept up today with everything happening
within the water foreigner and never
miss out one or nothing
if we stay subscribe to the channel but
that guys enjoy the rest of your day if
you're an American viewer happy July 4th
and yeah peace out
you
[Music]